this video is brought to you by
manscaped.com
find out more later in the video hey
42 here in 2005
two elderly japanese men stumbled out of
the thick
jungle on the island of mindanao in the
philippines
they claimed to be yoshio yamakawa aged
and suzuki nakuchi 85.
the two men were visibly confused and
were curious if the war had ended yet
now you may assume they were talking
about a recent war
iraq perhaps maybe it's a stretch
vietnam
given the region but no
these men were referring to the second
world war
that's right remarkably these two
japanese soldiers
had absconded into the filipino jungle
during the last froze of world war ii
and
had stayed there unaware of the outside
world
for 60 years
if you've been watching the channel
you'll know i'm a huge fan of manscaped
and their performance package kit it's
the world's first
all-in-one men's grooming kit that makes
trimming the hedges
safe and easy so that's your lawn in
order
but chaps what are you doing to seal a
deal
well wonder no more introducing the new
refined cologne signature scent by
manscaped
it's light and approachable but with a
pleasing masculine scent
ideal for the refined gentleman that you
are
refined is calming and inviting on the
nose
with a light citrus burst before
settling into the anchoring notes
of vetiver eventually landing on a
woodsy
masculine finish the 50 milliliter spray
cologne is hypoallergenic
cruelty free dye free paraben free and
100 vegan
and i just love the look of the bottle
it certainly makes a statement
on your dresser or in your gym bag and
since father's day is fast approaching
there really isn't a better gift for
your dear father
than refined cologne by manscapes the
performance package kit includes
the waterproof lawn mower 3.0
the weed whacker nose and ear hair
trimmer
the crop preserver ball deodorant the
crop reviver
ball toner and two free gifts
the shared travel bag and the manscaped
anti-chafing
high-performance boxer briefs go to
manscape.com forward slash
42 today and get 20
off plus free international shipping
plus two free gifts
link is in the description below your
balls
and your body will thank you a mediator
working for a japanese veterans group
told the japanese embassy in manila he
would deliver the men to the authorities
so they could finally return to their
homeland
a media storm followed in japan with the
nation gripped by this
incredible story but then the story
ended
the men failed to turn up to their
meeting with the mediator
and wary of the media they simply
disappeared
back into the jungle whilst the story of
yashio and tsuzuki
seems fanciful and to be fair it has
never been verified
there really have been japanese soldiers
who spent decades hiding out in jungles
in the philippines and across the rest
of asia
for one reason or another unaware that
the second world war
actually ended but how could this
possibly happen surely news of the end
of the last great global war
reached every obscure corner of the
world
surely weary but relieved soldiers
returned home on mass to their worried
families
well yes they did almost everywhere else
but across southeast asia thousands of
japanese
never returned home and the answer
to why that happened lies deep within
the bizarre military culture and customs
of the empire of japan
for japan world war ii provided the
golden opportunity
for imperial expansion whilst europe was
preoccupied fighting an
angry man with a nervous twitch in his
right arm
european colonies in asia were left
right for the taking
so japan spent the war stoking
anti-colonial sentiments in asian
colonies
what said colonies didn't realize
is this wasn't for the benefit of their
people
japan wanted all those lands for itself
having already added korea to the
japanese empire in 1910
and the chinese territory of manchuria
in 1931
japan was hungry for more it was an
imperialist machine that couldn't
and wouldn't be stopped although the
empire of japan
was powerful it lacked natural resources
something southeast asia had plenty of
but what the japanese did to get their
hands on these tropical bounties
will forever go down in history as some
of the most brutal
and inhumane acts of wartime aggression
we humans have ever done to one another
japan's military equipment wasn't as
cutting edge as the allies
but what they did have was an undying
loyalty
and extreme spiritual and moral
fortitude
japanese soldiers particularly officers
believed they must fight to the death at
all costs
and that surrender was synonymous with
shame
one historian nicholas harling described
the european reaction to the way the
japanese army fought as
horrified by its violence baffled by its
determination
impressed by its dedication and
there are no two ways about it the war
crimes carried out by the japanese
were pretty horrifying the japanese
people back home were told
their army was fighting to liberate
southeast asian countries
from centuries of colonialism in reality
they carried out mass beheadings and
bayoneted filipino babies
but their gruesome attempts to colonize
southeast asia
were short-lived because on the 6th of
august
1945 the japanese city of hiroshima
was devastated by an allied nuclear bomb
the first in history used against
civilians
three days later so was nagasaki
the war in europe had ended three months
earlier but the japanese empire refused
to surrender
however the death of approximately 200
japanese civilians and the devastation
of two huge cities left emperor hirohito
with little choice but even when
japanese surrender eventually came many
in japan
and japanese soldiers still fighting
abroad weren't really sure
what had actually happened emperor
hirohito
wasn't exactly churchill in fact
he'd never actually addressed his people
directly
until now and when he did
he forgot to actually tell them japan
had surrendered
instead choosing the following words
we have ordered the acceptance of the
provisions of the joint declaration
of the powers which if you ask me
is about as clear as custard to make
matters more confusing still
he delivered the speech in formal
classical japanese
which many people would have struggled
to understand
so a typically japanese understated
surrender declaration
coupled with the military's demand for
absolute
discipline and devotion meant that
some japanese soldiers just didn't know
when it was time to stop
in the years immediately following the
war thousands
kept on fighting right across southeast
asia
and the pacific islands they became
guerrilla fighters hiding out in the
jungles
and the mountains and getting into
skirmishes with allied soldiers and
local armies
and even civilians many simply didn't
believe
emperor hirohito's surrender broadcast
to be
real the japanese surrender
impossible many of these peace deniers
didn't last long one group
led by captain sake ober had been driven
into the jungle of the pacific island of
saipan
just before the war was over the island
then a japanese colony and home to
thousands of japanese civilians
was attacked and captured by u.s forces
in july 1944
after weeks of brutal fighting much of
it hand-to-hand combat
tens of thousands died including roughly
1 000
who jumped to their deaths off a cliff
to avoid the humiliation of surrender
captain ober on the other hand led
around
200 people the majority of them
civilians
into the jungle where they kept on
fighting
launching attacks for the undergrowth on
any u.s soldiers
who dared venture too close the problem
was
after japan surrendered ending world war
ii
on the 2nd of september ober and his men
refused to do the same and kept on with
their guerrilla assaults
eventually though in december 1945
oba surrendered in a surprisingly calm
manner
after a former japanese general managed
to get a message to him
that the war really was over captain oba
handed his sword to the americans and
returned to japan
where he became a successful businessman
dying in 1992
at the age of 78. nearby
just 75 miles away on the island of
anatahan
an altogether stranger story played out
once uninhabited and it constant threat
of volcanic eruption
this island unexpectedly became home
to a handful of plucky japanese coconut
farmers
when a japanese boat was sunk close to
the shore
in 1944 30 of the soldiers aboard
managed to swim to safety
and they were pretty safe ana hassan was
far too small and obscure
for the us to bother invading so
cut off from the outside world and with
no means of communication
the soldiers just about survived on
coconuts
fish lizards and wild sugarcane
they weren't going to be attacked
anytime soon especially after the war
ended
but still it's fair to say life wasn't
exactly idyllic
things did improve somewhat when an
american b-29 bomber crashed onto the
island
giving the soldiers metal to make into
knives and cooking pots
parachute silk for clothes nylon cords
for fishing lines
and pistols yeah
those pistols also proved to be their
undoing
there was a problem you see amongst the
castaway soldiers on anatahan
there was just one woman kazuko higa
who quickly became something of a femme
fatale
she married one of the soldiers but he
was swiftly
killed by another jealous castaway the
murderer
was then killed himself by another
soldier
who fancied his chances with kazuko
and as time went on so did the killings
in total 11 men out of the original 30
were murdered after becoming one of her
husbands
you just wouldn't bother trying would
you after seeing the third man get
killed
no woman is worth fighting off a small
army of hungry and horny japanese men
the situation wasn't helped by the fact
the japanese had now worked out how to
ferment
coconut wine so lazy day's hunting
lizards
soon turns to drunken brawls
the u.s authorities did occasionally
drop leaflets on the island
to let the soldiers know that the war
was over
but they chose not to believe them and
because they presented no threat
they were left to it by the outside
world
it was only in 1950 that kazoo kohiga
managed to flag down a passing u.s ship
she explained to them that the men
didn't believe the war was over
and so the u.s authorities passed
messages to the men's families back in
japan
when the men received letters in return
telling them that
the war had indeed finished five years
earlier
they finally surrendered and returned to
japan
in 1951. over the next two decades
multiple other japanese holdouts were
discovered
and cautiously surrendered with the
larger groups mostly found
those who emerged from the depths of the
jungle in later years
were usually solo fighters
in 1972 soichi yokoi was discovered
after 28 years on the remote island of
guam
yukoi had been posted to guam in 1943
and went into hiding with nine other
soldiers when it was captured in 1944
by 1964 there were just three of them
left
then when the other two were drowned in
a flood
yokoi was left alone despite his
predicaments
yokoi refused to surrender he later said
that he'd known
since 1952 that the war
was over but he just couldn't bring
himself to leave
instead he waited ready to help the
japanese army
who he was convinced would one day
return
to recapture the island
he was found in 1972 by two local
fishermen
assuming he was just a passing villager
they were about to leave him
be except yukoi reacted first
and attacked them hardly surprising that
many years of solitude spent living in a
hole in the ground
eating lizards had made yokoi a little
bit paranoid
oh and there was also the small fact
that he was still trying to win the war
for japan
all by himself but in this instance
it was two against one and the locals
managed to drag
yokoi out of his hiding place and back
to the nearest town
remarkably the american airbase on guam
was just two miles away from the jungle
hole in which he'd lived all that time
undetected yokoi became a celebrity when
he returned home
even making tv shows about his
experiences
when asked how he managed to stay hidden
for quite so long
he answered i was really good at hide
and seek
he lived until 1997 dying of a heart
attack
at the age of 82.
we don't know exactly how many japanese
holdouts are still living there
on the islands and jungles of the
philippines
probably not many now but they do keep
popping up occasionally
such as hiro honoda who lived in the
jungle
on the filipino island of lubang until
1974. he had taken to the mountains with
three other soldiers in 1945
the only survivors of an ill-fated
mission to hamper allied attacks
over the years attempts were made to
find the men
mostly because they periodically
attacked and killed local residents
leaflets were dropped informing them of
the end of the war
and even family pictures were attached
in an effort to persuade them
out regular search parties were sent out
and the last of onoda's companions was
found and
killed by police in 1972
but no matter what they tried honoda
refused to believe the war was over
but eventually honoda's former
commanding officer
flew to the philippines to tell him in
person
that it really was about time to
surrender and
so he did still wearing his
much worn very tacit uniform
then president of the philippines
ferdinand marcos
granted him a pardon despite the fact
he'd killed
30 innocent farmers in the years since
the war
in his solo campaign to fight on for
japan
marcos reasoned that he was just
following orders
and didn't know the war was over even
though
everyone kept trying to tell him when he
returned to japan
anada was welcomed as a hero when asked
why he didn't surrender
anadar simply explains that he was under
orders
every japanese soldier was prepared for
death
but as an intelligence officer i was
ordered to conduct guerrilla warfare
and not to die he said
he went on to run a series of survival
skills training schools in japan
and died in 2014
at the age of 91.
for watching check out my new podcast
random interesting facts available on
youtube
spotify apple podcast and anywhere else
you get your podcasts
link in the description below thanks